today we're talking about splinter cell
reportedly getting a new game the xbox
mini fridge selling out and being
scalped plus we're getting updates on
microsoft's first party studios and game
pass my name is devonte chisholm and
you're watching gamespot news
all right it's the moment you've all
been waiting for drum roll please
vgc's tom henderson reports ubisoft is
working on a new splinter cell game i'll
give you a moment to celebrate
all right that's enough let's keep going
according to the report the game is said
to be in the early phase of production
and there is a small chance it will be
announced in 2022 at the time of this
recording there is no insight on which
studios are working on the new splinter
cell but sources said the game may be
developed by a studio outside of
montreal ubisoft is reportedly green
lighting the game in part as a means of
quote winning back fans who didn't
embrace splinter cell's mobile or vr
spin-offs the report shed no light on
what type of game the new splinter cell
might be though it was described as
being a quote mainline entry as opposed
to some type of spin-off if it's real
this would be the first new splinter
cell game since 2013's splinter cell
blacklist leave a comment down below
letting me know which splinter cell you
think is the best one and no fighting no
fighting if you disagree
moving on to microsoft's newest piece of
hardware the xbox series x mini fridge
this 100 meme product went on sale this
morning and quickly sold out got review
bombed and emerged on auction sites for
ridiculous prices people who managed to
secure the fridge celebrated their
achievement on social media while many
others like me were not so lucky however
if you didn't secure a mini fridge
online the good news is that the
majority of the units will be available
in store at target so your best bet
might be to go to a store instead of
spamming the refresh button online
according to microsoft the mini fridge
should start appearing in stores this
december and keep in mind it can hold 12
cans so go out there and find some
canned water and stay hydrated all right
i really care about you
and in other microsoft related news xbox
boss phil spencer spoke at a wall street
journal event on monday and said
microsoft will definitely buy more
studios though there's no timeline for
when the deals might happen spencer also
didn't give any indication as to what
studios microsoft might be looking to
acquire but he has said that microsoft
wants to buy another japanese studio
microsoft's last big gaming acquisition
was xenomax bethesda which it paid 7.5
billion dollars to buy microsoft now has
23 game development studios spread
across the world working on a variety of
projects hit the comment section and let
me know what you want to see next from
microsoft's first party lineup
and speaking of xbox first party games
forza horizon 5 has officially gone gold
not much else to that story i'm just
really excited for the game's release so
i had to throw it in there
and you know what let's just keep this
xbox train rolling and talk about some
game pass arriving today october 19th is
the retro fps roguelike into the pit on
console cloud and pc while people can
fly shooter outriders joins the catalog
on pc that confuses you a little it's
because it was already on game pass on
console microsoft's own age of empires 4
comes to game pass on pc on october 28th
at launch and alan wake's american
nightmare also comes to game pass on
october 28th and it will be available
for console and pc the post noir action
game backbone which has you playing as a
raccoon detective comes to game pass on
october 28th as well alongside one of
2021's best games overall the time loop
game the forgotten city which lands on
game pass that day 2 for console cloud
and pc for a full rundown of the new
additions to game pass as well as the
games updated with touch controls make
sure you head over to gamespot.com
but alright that's it for me i already
gave you your homework to do in the
comments section so go do that and uh
follow me over on social media at
devonta chisholm and i'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
you